our shout out tonight to a brave and
determined journalism teacher at a
California high school who gave her
students and her bosses a real-life
lesson in how the First Amendment should
work the faculty adviser for the school
newspaper at Bear Creek High School in
Stockton California is Kathy duffle I
love my job I love my students I will
always protect their right to free
speech and she had to put her job on the
line this year when her students came up
with the story at the school
administration well certainly did not
want public we were sitting around
pitching story ideas as we normally do
and one of the students pitched this
story and said you know I've been
hearing a lot about a girl named Caitlyn
on our campus and she is a sex worker
and there's been some rumors about her
and maybe she would welcome the chance
to to set the record straight
eighteen-year-old Caitlyn Fink agreed to
be interviewed by the student papers
menon GN etre bailey Kirkeby when I
first began writing this story it was
supposed to be just another profile of a
student like we do every issue but
Caitlyn's story included how the senior
had been working as a model for a porn
agency selling nude videos of herself
and aspiring to become a stripper it
wasn't even on my radar for me it was
just another student profile that we
were doing but then she received this
threatening letter from the school
superintendent after word quickly spread
about what the student paper was up to
that said that if we were to publish the
story and not submit it for prior review
to her then I would be subject to
disciplinary action up to and including
dismissal what did you make of that um I
was shocked I think I cried a little bit
first I I didn't understand the
overreach but California is one of the
14 states in the country that limit
unreasonable interference by
administrators with student newspapers
and she sought help from the student
press Law Center by then things were
getting pretty ugly there were some
intimidating factors
work and I was feeling pretty
uncomfortable at that point what kinds
of things were the intimidating factors
did you think one of them was to send a
police officer who was waiting at my
door for me one morning questioning me
about sex trafficking and distributing
pornography to minors but Kathy duffle
did not back down a group of determined
high schoolers in Stockton have
published a feature article on a fellow
student who works in the porn industry
the story in the school paper the Bruin
voice described how Caitlyn Fink
considered her adult entertainment
career as a job just like any other job
as I'm sure everyone now sees the
content is not obscene in any way it's
merely just showing the story of a young
student at our school who is on her own
living her independent life and having
to navigate the world of the pornography
industry and I feel though that's an
important story to tell and so far the
school has backed off its threat to fire
Kathy Duffy I am still employed yes I
think it's always a question she
receives support after national news
coverage of the showdown but most
important to her is the reaction of her
students she's been such an inspiration
and
everyone at school not just our class
and
glad that she's still here
and what is there inside of you that
gave you this kind of gumption I think
because this is not my first rodeo with
the district I have had some pretty
knock-down drag-out fights over the
years they've been hurtful and so I I
still have something to prove I think to
this district that even after 33 years
me putting my job on the line means that
I am serious about free speech and I
will always hold them accountable
so our shout out tonight to Cathy duffel
like many of us in this profession my
own career was launched at a high school
newspaper in Highland Park Illinois the
shoreline to this day I remember and
unthankful from all I learned my
journalism teacher dr. John muttski
that's our program for tonight thanks
for watching we'll see you back here and
next week